on the border with ancient nubia
ramses built another massive monument
the mountain temple of abu simbel
colleen has come here searching for
clues about how
ramsay's military skill contributed to
the success of his empire
this is like the greatest hit of
ramsay's
victories
[Music]
ramsay's consolidated his empire in the
south
and pushed north to confront his
powerful enemies
the hittites
in temples all over egypt he recorded
his victory
against the hittites or so he wanted us
to think
around 1300 bc the egyptians
fought their arch rivals the hittites at
the fortress city of kadesh
in possibly the largest chariot battle
in history
the light egyptian chariots had the edge
over the heavy hittite war machines
ramses recorded the victory as a
massacre but in reality
it was more of a draw the two kings
agreed a truce
resulting in the world's first recorded
peace treaty
it enabled the egyptians to spend
all of their resources on peacetime
pursuits
building massive constructions like this
and
usher in a golden age for egypt
[Music]
instead of waging costly military
campaigns ramses built his success
through a mastery of diplomacy
[Music]
but to win the hearts of his citizens he
still needed
to depict himself as a mighty warrior
he's on his chariot alone with the reins
tied behind his back
so that he's free to shoot his bow
we know that this is a little bit of
propaganda because even the hieroglyphic
text
says that his shield bearer mena was
riding in the chariot with him
ramses was a master of ancient public
relations
happy to bend the truth to promote an
image which would appeal to his people
in the temple's inner sanctum colleen
discovers another secret of ramsay's
success
[Music]
here by placing his statue between the
greatest gods of egypt
ramses used a clever trick of the light
to engineer his own divinity
twice a year the sun rays reach
all the way through the temple
illuminating
these figures in the sanctuary
colleen believes ramses used this solar
alignment
to convey a powerful message that he was
the living embodiment
of the sun god
truly here at abu simbel ramses ii
is not just a king he is a god
[Music]
you